all I could say to start the show is
welcome to another week of yes this is
really happening I don't know if you saw
what happened this morning but Donald
Trump a 70 year old man and father of
five when apeshit on Twitter between 320
and 5:30 in the morning slut-shaming
Miss Universe 1996 that's the true part
remember Hillary's and from 2008 who do
you want answering the White House phone
at 3:00 a.m. how about someone who's not
already enraged in a hissy fit how about
but getting ahead of myself what let me
go back to the beginning America used to
be a country no okay not that far let's
go back to Monday night did you see the
debate okay the debate interesting
debate Hillary made her case for being
president that she has the experience
and the temperament to be the commander
in chief Donald Trump made his case I
hate Rosie O'Donnell but she started it
is this really happening
Trump interrupted her 51 times at one
point she had to say mommy's talking
mommy
he actually had a meltdown Donald Trump
had a meltdown about what a great
temperament he has it was like watching
someone carp I'm not a psycho into their
eyes i I can't process it anymore and
even though all the polls say that
Hillary won the debate
I know he won he won it and if even if
he didn't win totally not his fault the
moderator asked the wrong questions he
had a bad microphone the whole system is
rigged
she had the questions beforehand the Sun
was in my eyes the coke wore off I mean
eight
even Ryan Lochte was like stop with the
[ __ ] about being wrong you whiny
little [ __ ] I mean well I don't know
Hillary got a big bump after the debate
and Trump looked like he did a big bump
before the debate I'm hearing I don't
know it for a fact I hope it's not true
a lot of people are saying it a lot of
people are saying it that's all I know I
hope it's not true well you know he was
sniffing a lot it was either that or
he's allergic to facts
I think it may be the case Donald Trump
was born with a silver spoon in his nose
well I only say that because I mean he
came out absolutely manic the first half
hour charging like a rabid weasel
sniffling Kottonmouth kept drinking
rambling like the guy you can't get out
of your apartment and then most
tellingly 30 minutes in crashed did you
notice that ironically the guy who wants
to build the wall hit a wall which which
was actually the best part of the whole
night because he went after Hillary on
stamina stamina
she was Bruce Springsteen just getting
warmed up after 90 minutes
he was fat Elvis forgetting the lyrics -
are you lonesome tonight
[Applause]
which brings me back to miss you purpose
within what I was starting with yes so
he went after the stamina thing so she
said you know what this is really about
what you were talking about with women
for years looks and he said at night she
said you called Miss Universe 1996 Miss
Piggy okay that was Monday here it is
Friday morning and this nincompoop is
still obsessed with it he was treating
all night about miss 1996 she's
disgusting imploring people to check out
her sex tape yes Donald Trump
major-party nominee who wants to be the
President of the United States is urging
the American public to check out a sex
tape that doesn't exist from a
Venezuelan reality show
Republicans out there thank you so much
for this thank you so much you must be
so [ __ ] proud that your candidate
finally takes a concrete position on
something and it's no fat chicks
and this is how Trump treats pageant
contestants imagine how he treats poor
Melania